foreign
's YouTube channel in the session we
will be learning the threads in Java or
the multi-threading in Java but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt the latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's get started with our
agenda for today's session
so we will get started by understanding
what exactly is multiprocessing then we
will understand the different types of
multi-processing then we will get into
the thread where we will understand what
exactly is a thread and how the thread
Works in Java programming then we will
understand the multi-threading paradigms
then the thread life cycle and followed
by that we will get into the
technicalities of thread where we will
understand the thread definition and how
to access the thread methods and how to
run it started and you know the life
cycle of a thread and how to end it
followed by that we will get into some
most frequently used thread methods in
Java I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now without further Ado let's get
started
but before that if you are an aspiring
full stack developer or the one who is
looking to upskill your skills in full
stack development then we have a perfect
course for you from Simply learn we have
the postgraduate program and full stack
development which should help you to
accelerate your career as a software
developer through the most important
skill set that you will be requiring in
the real-time environment the key
features for this particular
postgraduate program are you will be
having the Caltech cdme postgraduate
certificate enrollment in simply launch
job assist receive up to 25 CEUs from
Caltech ctme and simply learns job
assist helps you get noticed by top
hiring companies master classes thought
by Caltech ctme instructors eight times
higher interaction and live online
classes conducted by industry experts
online convocation by caltex ctme
program director 20 lesson and and phase
and projects Capstone projects and four
domains Caltech ctme Circle membership
and build your own portfolio on GitHub
apart from this you will be guided
through this particular learning path
where you will have a brief introduction
to Catholic pgp program and
implementation of oops with Java
becoming a backend expert implementing
Frameworks by devops way develop a web
application using front-end stack full
stack web development Capstone project
and apart from that you will have some
more electives where you will go through
Caltech ctme full stack development
masterclass and The Phase 5 which
happens to be testing in devops
lifecycle
the skills that will be covered
throughout this entire program are agile
spring core 50 AWS soap and rest Java
devops JavaScript es6 JSP hibernate and
jpa HTML5 and css3 and finally the
serblets and also you will be worked
through some of the most important tools
like angular CSS Docker get HTML Jenkins
junit 5 Maven mongodb MySQL rabbitmq
selenium Etc
you will be also covering the most
important projects for your portfolio
which will include the fintech sector
food delivery services entertainment
sector and much more and here are our
program advisors Rick and finally we
have the career support so what are you
waiting for enroll today to our pgp
program in full stack web development
now let's get back to our PPT and learn
about the threats in Java so the first
subheading which is what is
multi-processing
so back in the day when the computers
were a new thing the processors had only
one single call and they used to execute
tasks or the scheduling of the task was
one after the other one process was
supposed to be finished and then the
next would come up right so now what is
multi-processing so these days the
latest computers come up with multiple
core processes right here even the
processors are highly powerful but they
can execute multiple processes in one
single go or you can consider they can
execute multiple tasks fairly with
respect to each other right so the
process of using the complete bandwidth
of a CPU to execute two or more
computational jobs at a time as defined
as multi-processing now there are two
different types of multi-processing
so the two different types are basically
process based and thread based so both
are completely you know similar to each
other but they have some minute
differences what are the differences
basically they both execute the same
task right they take care of two or more
mathematical or logical processes to be
executed parallely with respect to each
other what's the difference yeah they
might seem same but the thinnest line of
difference is when we look into the
process based multi-processing it runs
two or more processes concurrently and
threads they execute two or more threads
concurrently so what is the difference
between a process and the thread right
now let's assume that you have opened
your internet browser and in the one tab
you are browsing through your internet
and in a different tab you are scrolling
through your social media platform say
Twitter Facebook or YouTube right here
those are considered as different
processes
right you are trying to open up
different tabs on your Google browser or
any internet browser and apart from that
let's say you are trying to execute a
code and you have opened your IDE say
eclipse or pycharm or something so when
you're browsing through internet you get
some source code and try to copy it and
try to run it on your ID so these are
considered as multi-processes right
multiple processes so this is process
space multi processing when you come
into thread based you just open up one
single application let's say your boss
told you to write down a document for
deal right now you're processing a deal
or you're trying to give a presentation
to your client or something and you are
trying to prepare that particular
document on Microsoft Word or Microsoft
PowerPoint which forever may it is
right and your process is to type in the
text or add the information onto your
IDE or let's say you are trying to add
information onto your word right and
here Microsoft Word is taking care of
multiple things in the background it is
taken care of you know the spelling it
is taking care of grammatical issues it
is taking care of indentation it is
taking care of font Etc right so here
multiple threads are running to execute
a single task right this is where you
can Define the difference between
process based and thread paste so
another difference is process based
multi-processing requires more time and
more memory compared to the thread base
whereas the thread based
multi-processing will consume less time
and less memory since only one
application is running there and the
last difference is it requires separate
address space so the process based
multi-processing will require separate
individual address for for each and
every process you are running the
background so one address for browsing
to internet one address for executing
your IDs Etc and here when you're
running one single application so one
single address space is shared by
multiple threads you will be having one
single main thread and that particular
thread is responsible for creating or
eliminating any child threats we will
understand this particular process in
the next following sections but let's
say let's understand that there will be
one single main thread which will start
the entire application and that
particular thread or main thread is
responsible for any of the future
upcoming child threats right so this is
the thinnest line of difference between
the processed space multiprocessing and
thread based multiprocessing
moving into our next subheading we can
see what is a threat right so what
exactly is a thread
so here you can see one image and this
particular image can be considered as an
application so let's say you are going
to start an application let's say you're
starting your Eclipse IDE then you start
your application this particular
processor will start the main thread
inside that particular operation or that
particular application right and that
particular main thread is responsible
for creating multiple child threads so
the hierarchy goes in this way when you
start an application that particular
application will receive a request or a
process from the user let's say you are
trying to open the IDE or let's say
you're trying to open an existing file
in your computer system that's the
request what you send right based on
that request that particular request
will be processed by starting a main
thread and that particular main thread
will look is there a requirement for any
of the child threads to be created for
this particular process or request and
accordingly it will give birth to
multiple child threads and it will get
the job executed or it will get the job
done so every thread will have a job and
that particular job will be inside the
thread body and it will be executed by
accessing that particular thread body so
we will look how the fundamentals or how
the process or how the life cycle of a
thread goes on in the next particular
segment now moving ahead into the next
part a thread is the smallest unit of
execution or a processor allocates time
to threads every thread has a program
counter to keep track of the next Duty
remember I said one single main thread
will create the multiple threads or
child threads right so each and every
thread will have a program counter which
will take care where to go and what part
of the code to be executed right
sometimes you call a function and the
entire control will be sent into that
particular function body and the main
body will be waiting for a response from
that function it can be anything it can
be the data or it can be the control
which comes out of the function after
the execution right and after that every
thread has a stack to arrange the
priority of jobs allocated every thread
has a set of registers and every thread
has its own unique ID however a thread
cannot execute itself it needs a program
or a process you cannot start a thread
unless you start or unless you give a
request or any kind of you know
operation to the application and finally
multi-threading can be only be possible
on multi-core processor so if you have a
single core processor you cannot do it
the processor should be capable to
execute multiple processors at one
single go it should be capable to finish
multiple process in parallel with each
other it should not have scheduling like
one after the other so that can be
possible only multi-processor based
computers only
now in the next sub heading
what is multi-threading
right as shown in the above figure a
thread is executed inside a process and
there is context switching between the
threads there are multiple processes
inside the OS and one process can have
multiple threads remember I said you
when an application is started it
receives a request or it receives an
operation or a process from the user and
based on that process request or
operation the main thread will start the
execution process and that particular
main thread is responsible for creating
multiple threads in one group based on
the requirement right so here you can
see one application got started and it
started up multiple processes process a
process B process C right the process
can be interdependent or process can be
individual or they are not dependent on
each other it is based on what kind of
application you are running right the
process can be dependent on each other
or it can be independent and it can run
on its own So based on the requirement
the context switching happens between
the processes right so these are the
threads and these are the individual
process of process a process p and
process C let's say process a is
dependent on the result or the output
which comes from process B until that
time this particular threads and process
a are idle right and if say process a is
supposed to be giving the output to
process B which is dependent on process
A and C together then the threads in
process B will be idle until the control
comes to that particular end right
that's how multi-threading works that's
the meaning here which says context
switching happens between the threads
right now moving on to the next sub
heading
the next subheading will explain us the
thread life cycle right we already have
a brief understanding how a thread
starts what's the hierarchy of a process
what's the hierarchy of a main thread
than the child threads right now let us
understand let's keep that aside and let
us understand the thread life cycle of
every thread whether it is a child
threat or whether it is a main thread
every thread will go through this
particular life cycle let's understand
what's that life cycle is
so the life cycle starts from new
runnable running waiting and dead this
particular runnable plays a major role
because every single thread whatever the
thread you define that particular thread
will only have one function which is run
right we will be dealing that in the
next segment but now let us understand
what exactly each and every one of these
stages is having an importance right
let's go through the first stage and
that is new
the first stage in every threads life
cycle is new
the brand new thread is created using
thread clause and thread will be in this
state until the program is sent for
execution so whenever you click on the
application the application will start
and the new threads are readily
dispatched for every process right until
the process is clicked upon until the
process is started these style threads
or the thread whichever started will
remain in the new state right it will
not start
whenever the request is received then
the stage will change from new to
runnable the thread gets engaged with
the instruction here the thread gets
assigned to a scheduler and scheduler is
responsible if the threads execute or
not once the threads receive the
execution order the threads will get
into the running state from the runnable
state here it will store the potential
to execute a task in the random State
once the potential is given the order
then it starts executing the job the
thread starts executing the instruction
and this stage is called as running
stage the scheduler borrows the thread
from the thread pool the thread pool is
where all the runnable or new threads
are available and once a scheduler gets
the job it borrows the threats from the
pool and gets them running and gets the
job executed and remember I said in a
multi-processing stage you will be
having multiple threads and in case if
there is a dependency let's say process
a is supposed to be receiving an input
or an output or a control from another
process until then the process B will be
in idle state that particular idle state
is called as waiting state so the thread
goes into the waiting stage as it is
dependent on a different process to
receive the control or the input now
let's get into the next stage that is
the dead stage the final stage is where
the thread gets killed after the process
execution is done after the termination
stage the threat enters to the debt
condition let's say the process could
completely execute it and there is no
reason why the thread is still active
then automatically the scheduler or the
main thread well terminate the executing
child thread or the waiting whichever
the state it is if the process is done
the child thread whichever finished
execution will go into the death state
so this is the thread life cycle moving
into the next subheading we will
understand the process of
thread creation
so Java threads can be created in two
different ways that is extending the
threat loss and using a runnable
interface now let us understand the
first way of creating threats that is
extending a thread class
so so far we have understood the thread
terminology what is multi-processing
what is the different types of
multiprocessing thread and what is
multi-threading Etc and we also know
that to execute threats in Java we need
to you know execute the thread class
right and what if you wanted to create
multiple threads
based on the fundamentals of oops it is
already evident that you cannot inherit
multiple inheritances right so far we
have understood that to execute a threat
we had to inherit the thread class which
is the superclass in Java and if you
want to execute a thread you need to
inherit the thread properties from the
thread super classic server right now
let's say we had the process or let's
say we had a dependency where we had to
create multiple threads now it is edited
we cannot inherit the threat class
multiple times for all the individual
threats that's where the interface comes
into picture now we have something
called a runnable interface in Java now
we will be overriding that runnable
interface to get the thread job executed
so you can see here this particular code
segment is called as thread definition
so to implement the runnable interface
you will write the class A which will be
implementing the runnable interface and
inside that you will be overriding the
run method which is the only method
available in thread interface or run
interfer runnable interface of java and
inside this particular run function
whatever you write is considered as the
threadshow which can be anything which
can be printing a simple message or it
can be a for Loop or it can be a
condition or any Duty whatever you want
to execute in terms of software is
called as a thread job which is always
encapsulated inside the Run function of
the runnable interface
and when you come into thread execution
you create a new class B which will
implement the runnable interface and
inside that you will be having the
public static point mean string arcs so
until here you will have one single
thread that is the main thread which
will be you know called by the jvm and
once you create the new object of the
main thread then a new thread will be
generated that is the child thread which
is responsible for executing the job
which is present in the runnable
interface and the main thread will be
available as it is this particular main
thread will have the job of executing
the objects or whichever the code you
have the job which is related to the
class B and it will be dedicated to that
job only the child through which you
create the new thread will execute the
chair thread job which is in the
runnable interface so this is how you
can create a thread by extending an
existing thread class
now let's try to execute an example
based on this particular type of thread
creation
so on my screen you can see an example
for extend method where we are going to
extend an existing thread class and try
to create the multi-thirating operation
so the third job here is in between the
try and catch block which is a for Loop
which will just run for four times until
this particular condition is true and
try to print a message thread and the
name of the thread right and every
thread creation will have a 50
millisecond sleep timer now let's try to
quickly execute this class our code and
see the output so here you have the main
thread or the main extend class right
and here we have the thread creation or
we are calling the start function using
the extending method
let's select the code and execute this
particular code
there you go the code got executed and
here we have the output the creation of
thread one and two and the thread names
the threads which are running is thread
2 and the threads which have died after
the execution is thread one and two
right so we created this particular one
two three four threads and the current
threads which are three and four are
maybe in the waiting State or the
routable state and the two threads which
are executed are debt are the thread one
and two so with that let's go into the
next type of theoretic creation which is
the runnable interface right now we get
into the next type of thread creation
which is using the runnable interface it
is completely similar we will have the
thread definition Class A implements
runnable and public static word mean and
here we have the thread shop and when
you come into class P right remember in
the previous method we just directly
created the T start right T dot start
method and which created the thread job
I mean X secure started executing the
thread show but when you come into
runnable interface things are quite
different now here
to access or to start the thread job or
to run the thread job this particular
Class B will not have the control over
this particular thread show right you
cannot directly add in the start and
ignore directly add in the run method
here and expect it to run
so what are we creating is we are trying
to create a new object right the object
of this particular class and that
particular object of this class will be
accessed by the thread so here we're
creating a thread again thread T is
equals to new thread and we are passing
this particular object to the thread
method and through this we are getting
the start function T dot start will
start executing the thread shop in the
class A so this is how the runnable
interface works now let's go through an
example based on this particular way of
creating a thread
so here on my screen you can see we have
the runnable way of implementing threads
right we have created an object of the
class and we are passing that particular
object here and we are accessing the
thread through the start method and here
the job is again simple just via you
know encapsulating the job inside the
try and catch block and it is again a
simple for Loop which should print the
message and the thread details let's
quickly execute this program and see the
output
there you go the program got
successfully executed again we have
created multiple threads here one two
three four the threads
two three four
now the threads three and four are in
the waiting State and or you can also
consider that they are in the running
State and the ones and two threads which
have completely finished their tasks are
in the exiting stage or dead state and
now let's move ahead into the next part
of our PPT which is about the most
frequently used thread methods
so some of the most frequently used
thread methods are run sleep is alive
suspend and resume as the name itself
suggests the run method is used to do an
action so remember the runnable
interface will have only one single
method which is run right so whatever
the job you define or whatever the job
you construct in the class is run by
this particular method right and the
next one is sleep
foreign
for a specific amount of time if you
want to hold the execution of a
particular thread then you can Define
this Sleep Method and add the number of
milliseconds for which you want to hold
that particular thread next is the lab
is alive can be considered as a Boolean
type of method where you can just check
if a thread is alive or not it will
return a value which is based on the
activity of that particular thread and
you can use that for the further
processing next is the suspend method
which will suspend an executing thread
let's say you want to forcefully stop a
particular thread then you can use the
suspend method and finally resume in
case if a thread is in Waiting stage not
in the dead stage if it is in the
waiting stage then you can start
resuming the activity of that particular
thread by using the resume method to
have a better understanding of each and
every method we have discussed here
let's execute a program based on each
and every method let's get back to the
eclipse idea
we are back on the Eclipse IDE
so here we have the simple program to
help us understand how a run method
actually works so here we are creating
the method run objective method run
which is Run 1 and here we are creating
a thread right remember the
implementation of runnable interface
where we created an object of the main
class that is the method run and then we
created an object of thread and then we
passed the thread.1 along with the run I
mean start function to execute this
particular job which is inside the main
run method which is the thread job to
print the function or print a message
which says that it is running right
let's execute this particular program
and see here
so there you go the program got executed
and here we can see the thread job is
being executed which is print a message
which says thread is running now let's
get into the second one which is Sleep
Method and here we have the
we have the third job encapsulated in
between the try and catch functions
block or you can say try and catch block
and here we have the Sleep Method where
we are calling the sleep function by
providing 500 milliseconds hold right so
when you execute this program the thread
creation thread one and thread 2 will
have a difference of 500 milliseconds
now let's execute this program and see
the
there you go the program got
successfully executed and the Sleep
Method is being executed here
right so with that let's move on to the
next method I presume it could be the
ease alive method
so let's close this console and we have
the program here
now here is alive is the main class and
the thread job is encapsulated between
try and catch blocks
and here we have the start function for
starting the thread and we are passing
the ease live method to check if the
created thread is alive or not let's try
to execute this program
there you go the program got executed
and here you can see the run method and
is alive is true that is the threads
which got created are alive and one of
the threads
right one of the two threads is alive
and another is false and here you can
see which thread is alike now we have
executed is alive run sleep and here we
have resume method let's get into the
resume method let's close the console
so here we are trying to suspend some
threads here you can see thread number
one two and threader number two is
started here and here we're calling the
suspend function for thread number two
right and again we are calling the
thread number two again with the resume
function right and in between these two
we are trying to start a new thread
which is thread number three let's try
to execute this program and see the
output
there you go
so here you can see the thread number
three has been created right so the
thread which was suspended it got
reactivated again in this particular
section
right and we are continuing again with
the number for the thread number four
now that leaves us to the last method to
purchase the suspend method and we
already had an example of suspend method
in the resume method all we are doing is
just trying to hold or stop one
particular method by calling the suspend
method let's try to quickly execute this
program and close the Practical session
there you go the thread number three got
suspended all right now here you can see
the creation of thread number zero the
main thread one two three four and the
thread three which got suspended here
and we again continued with the number
four right so
so with that let's get back to the PPT
so here we have all the five methods run
sleep is a live suspend and resume and
with that we have come to an end of this
session on threats in Java or multi
threading in Java if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if we require
the resources like PPT demo and the code
used in this particular session then do
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here